Yes, we already have wild demonstrations
here. I think that climate adhesives
weren't so
bad that they were aggressive, but
they have already
blocked things that I don't
think are good. Things have simply been destroyed, so I
still think that we  Some
things I just don't
think are great that they're happening in Germany,
so don't worry about
my own safety yet, but
we're all going in the right direction and
we have a positive attitude,
we want to get better, we want to
be more peaceful, we want more  Do sports,
think more, do more good things or do
we have more and more mobs and more and
more fights in the street and
burning cars and things like that, those are
the pictures that get me hi Frank, yes,
thank you for allowing me to be here, GLB
no, we were already there  But it's been a long time,
I don't know a few years and I
just wanted to tell you, it's amazing what
you've built, I just
walked in and experienced it all, I
interviewed all the people directly,
yeah, what's going on and stuff like that and it's really just
amazing how OMR  and your company
has developed, you
now have broader management,
deep respect, I know how difficult it is,
so many people, I don't even know if I'm
allowed to say how many, so I'm allowed to manage
over 400 crazy [ __ ], very nice
to be here again today  Yes,
thank you very much, so we see each other regularly at the
festival and here and there in the
scene, but we haven't been here
in Hamburg for a long time, so I'm happy and
there's a lot to talk about, as I
think you have since the last time  We've
also done a podcast up and down, you have to
say, tell me a
little bit about what you're
most concerned with, what's on your mind, what's
your focus right now, and that's certainly
a lot of public
knowledge now, is the fund we have
after we  Venture capital where you
invest privately in the
companies, we
decided to make it public in the stock market
and
the disadvantage and the advantage of that is
that it is very visible, which means you really
know
what you have on a daily basis  the team is investing there and how are
the prices going down and we
said yes we are focusing on
technology on smaller technology
not the Amazons and not the
Apple but the tech behind them
have the competence and and do
that and then we just have  invested in the
time when the
interest rates suddenly disappear from the macro issue because
when inflation has risen very sharply, they
have risen more sharply than they have in 40 years, which is
the result that we have now
seen in the venture capital and startup industry  The money has
become very expensive and as a result
these share prices have fallen very sharply.
In the venture capital sector they
try to cover this up a bit
by putting a triple liprf
or something like that on it and saying let's
try to keep the old price for a long time
But of course the
maltepils by which we measure
sales have also come back completely and that's
why our fund
fell relatively sharply at the top by -50%,
so of course a very, very difficult
start and that also gave a lot,
um yes, first of all  Headwind and and and
criticism that was certainly very difficult,
um, but we'll continue to build on it in peace, we'll
build up the team. I've never been more
bullish than ever before because I
see how strong the companies are and
how now the whole thing
is irrationally undervalued again before we had it
Certainly also a certain hype phase
and we are now working our way
through it slowly and well. Let's say in absolute
numbers, I think he had a V
raced to greater than 200 million, no,
you raced no V at all, that works exactly exactly,
it also works differently, you report it  It's
basically at the Barf that everything
is hyped up and then you have to, I think,
no, you don't even have to
want that, only the partners in the
background then see that, they
usually say that you have to put 10 million into it,
but in the industry there
There is also no regulation for and then
we have
collected 140 million in capital
externally but now also over 15
million from me which
is also in there from my own money and that is exactly what we
have from such a fund
boutique, there are the big ones, the DWS
Jens ehhard the big ones and the
others are called boutiques, they are
smaller independent players who are
not attached to the bank, we have
certainly had one of the fastest
and best starts for such a new
fund in the industry, okay in terms
of size  But
then, due to this
momentum or this development, it
became around 70 million, this gen yes no
alind even more now we are Bo I
think at almost 90 what we
have in management 90 mil but
then a mixture of loss of value, so to speak  In
this case and new inflows that
still come exactly and
of course not everyone invested at the peak,
but people also
invested later than the fund started a trangeche,
for example at €25, then we
also have people at €20 and at €18 and at €25  17
and at 16 invested and exactly but
so to speak W with you W always says Skin in
the game that for not there is always a
certain level of trust or a
certain honesty that forces it
and if you say you put 15 million
into it then it became that
also for you, which is hard then
seven or or eight or so um yes and
no so for the most part I
invested a very large part right at the start because I also wanted to show the team
that DAH was behind it but we
had it again afterwards  Returns from
the venture capital business and
I then invested them later, as they say,
dollar cost average,
but overall of course I have
a big loss, so definitely
in the position at the moment
and that's exactly the skin in the game is
absolute  Since my wife, family,
friends, partners are also invested there
and we're doing it very long-term and
very seriously, we're doing the whole thing,
we're all really involved
because I mean, that sounds so strange
in this day and age, so I'll just put it down
now  The ball will probably be dropped,
we'll say yes, but please give an
honest answer if you say a 50%
loss
is maybe not that
bad, so I mean there are a lot of
titles I spoke to tar a short time ago,
it's in the e-commerce sector
pretty good in his peer group
but I think he has also lost over 50%
since the IPO in this case and
he says there are companies in his
peer group that have lost 90% in
value since their peak,
at least that's the average
Goldman one  Investment bank that is building
one of those, the biggest, sorry, I
wanted to be a very, very large
investment bank, you have a very broad
audience, which is very good, that's why
an investment bank that I think
is very well recognized has
built a basket of nonprofitable tech,
so tech companies  in the stock market
but they are not profitable, they are on
average - 90% currently that's
exactly why we are actually from that
because we are only there once and we do
n't time it and we
don't postpone either but we say we
only invest in technology in one  In a slightly
earlier phase, the companies are
already stable and currently have at least
two years of cash runway and so on,
but all of a
sudden we would now invest in Amazon not because we think it's good,
but rather because of our
strategy, there is an exception, and
MS has to explain why that
is where we invest and
if you look at such a non-profitable
day we also have profitable
companies then they are at - 90%, that is
actually exactly what we mean, we even did
relatively well in the market,
but that is still bad
Absolutely, I'm also sorry for everyone
who invested there, with me,
I think in the long term it will work very well,
but I'm also very,
very grateful that we don't have any outflows
but even inflows
and and so on because the investors continue to
trust them  I like it from
Tarek, who you know very well if
you don't have his share price
in mind right now, but he will
probably
have really lost money, although
if you talk to him, a company like that is
probably developing well, yes, yes, yes
So that's at least stable and
none of them have any operational issues, I
think they all have their big warehouses
full, so to speak, I think construction is
no exception but not even close to that,
that doesn't exactly reflect irrational or
very strong sales because that's why
I think it's very important  Because
whenever you talk about stocks and so on,
of course there is no investment
advice or recommendation, very very very
important, neither from you nor from me,
but at the moment I can see that I have
also been a tech investor for a very long time, which is what
we are currently looking at in terms of reviews  see
and malultipils is already very, very
attractive, that means I'm actually looking forward
to the next few months, we're
currently hanging on the macro needle, that
means what do the central banks say,
we have another war and these
topics are currently crucial,
our companies in the 10x1a
portfolio are delivering  outstanding
numbers right now Oscar came
out a few hours ago hims was yesterday
oscar is the insurance I was the
reasons also a few months ago and great
Mario Mario Mario yes Mario
delivered exactly great numbers now
I don't know how the share
will react today but exactly to the
companies  things are actually going
really well but the market is saying
Bo little TEAG I don't want that and
now we have to see if you have the courage
to invest in it then it
definitely feels like a
historically good opportunity okay let's say a
little bit  personal
reports when you have such a development
and also work with the money from investors,
what was the worst moment for
you so there were people who were at diron ha
house from the house human Frank these were my
vacation plans here I don't know
or my retirement plans were
them  now mater are or there were
moments when you said what have I
done here or or do you say well in the end
everyone can
handle it that was really very very it
was a challenging time for me and
I always at the start of the fund and
always today  I also said, be careful, this
is a volatile product, I've always
used this sentence, this is the wrong
product if you
want to buy larger Christmas presents, so
you should invest in the short term, this is a
product that takes time and that's why
I've never had a bad conscience,
I think for what  It
was a bit depressing for me and that's
after all the successes I had in mind,
but then perhaps it's fair
enough how hard some people and
editors used that to
write down a little bit of Frank Telen, yes, that was because of
that  Then it was just off the bar and it looked
a bit stupid. No one was
interested in how other funds
that had similar strategies performed anymore, they just
looked at it and now they took advantage of it
and that was a bit
stressful. That's exactly what I had
sometimes too  annoyed, but I think I'm
over it now. You
've said a few
words about the portfolio, what has the
most? There are companies that
keep the portfolio at the top, so they
have pushed this performance, so they are now doing
well despite all the negative developments  We
also ran well in terms of numbers, for
example in the first
half of the year now this year. We
also had a 60% improvement in form, so
we showed a good
performance because we were one of
the best for now it came
again  The interest rates stayed longer than
expected, so the interest rate level and then it
goes down again, so we have
often shown that if the
market
is just at a standstill in the interest rate environment, then I
think we have a very good
portfolio  I think companies
that pushed this above all else
are
still at a loss. I think Oscar is running
very well. We've already
sold companies again because we
invested in the early phase and we
have them and then we also went out
to Shopify  In between we got
a good impression, a
Palantier is running excellently, but even more
important to me is how
they develop internally and
they are really showing a lot of strength right now,
okay, and there are some positions where you
say wow, we're really unlucky
Position no, I think what, for example, the
cryptocash we also have around 5%
crypto exposure there was certainly
Bitcoin in part but they are now back
up to 30 I think 3
and Ether that was certainly difficult
but no overall okay okay so at the
same time you have  But in the venture
world I had a few episodes, so I
think I have the biggest win of all time,
I've now got it, it must have been wfood for you,
that may be the case, it ca
n't be Spreen, yes exactly so we
but we that's crazy when you
look at dhdl  which is often
criticized, we really have
several hundred million in sales just from
our dadl startups that we generated,
so something like that, some of which we also
sold and some of which we didn't
sell, that was a
really great success in monetary terms and
I have to too  To be fair, because
I can't sell our venture capital portfolio right now,
we're also doing tech, which means there
aren't any big tech exits right now. We
've seen lean IX at SAP
from Bonn, but that was just a pure one  There
were others in your case too, it
was a coincidence, so to speak. In general, there are
n't that many exits at the moment and
we were now able to generate
really nice liquidity with the food portfolios,
which we can now place in the
tech market. That was
great that we did it, but
I'm out  from dadl and we do
n't make food anymore but it was very great
okay the two biggest ones so
we've already talked about Ankerkraut I think that
was a successful ex for very
successful ne and then W food there's
now at least Nestle
bought half of it or something like that  I also
read that, I believe that,
I believe that and W is simply a great
company, so what they
created a few months ago or at the
beginning of the year I would have said the
sizes were right here
and I think it's running now  Towards
200 or something like that, maybe
S are already over there, yes, and you're there,
so to speak, with them on TV at the time,
the
purchase prices are sometimes quite attractive, which you can
see in retrospect, so it was public,
yes, I think for 22% for €200,000  or
SAS that wasn't yes that was very good
we also pitched in no we
also then that's our thing we
really go with us to
Rewe with us to Edeka so we help build
the companies on that's what we have
We've already done a lot and that's why we have so much in our food portfolio, even
a litzer almost a
lot of things that have become successful, sometimes
the biggest but on and WF or have I
overlooked something? There's another bigger one
that's not exactly DDL, a
bit  Air up because it was also at that time
and we also went into the trade
and so they have that
wasn't that wasn't in the show
exactly but that's what I would say
that's that's significantly more
successful than wfood for  wow really maybe so
I think they are very
very good yes something for you then
these three
investments are life changing again or
now bigger than your initial
investments that got you on the show
probably even yes so definitely
that is very very
big, of course we have in the tech sector
because K maybe
talk about it right away, there are even bigger things
going on right now, but right now we don't have any
liquidity problems, yes, you're laughing, but
you, we have, we
built up venture capital, I sold my first
company then then then then
We ran into it with our own money
then a few friends like Christian
Reber helped out a bit, but
we also had
a real liquidity problem at times because we do
n't have any cash flow, so we don't have anything that could
bring us money in every month or every year and we had  In the last few years
I still remember exactly
where we really looked at how we could
finance everything again because you
also need new money to
make new investments and I've been doing this
with Mark Sieberger and Alex Koch
for decades and we have that
too  had really difficult times
where the company and everything was
actually going quite well, but
in venture capital you have if you don't
have any big LPs that we don't have,
sometimes if you
don't sell the company you run into real
liquidity problems no matter how
rich you are  on paper but you
also did that, I think it
was also a trick of yours that was cleverer in the end,
you also took advantage of
the opportunity on the show to not only
invest your own money but also from
a fund in the background
investing in so was mostly
under money only two people were there one
is Christian Reber with whom we
built wunderlis a very close friend
Pitch these days and many other things
Interface has just founded VC and
another local very
successful entrepreneur and that  That's it, but
it was mainly always our
money and now in the current
generation it's 100% our money, so
we don't have any significant
external capital and currently we don't have any at all.
Okay, the kind of tech portfolio
you have now. There are also
things
I think it's relatively big in there now, I think it's relatively big.
It's still going
well, so we're very, very
happy with what's happening there, but also since
you just mentioned central, it's
of course a software as a service
business like B2B like a personio and
That also has a lot of
capital in the account, it's great
to have Tiger in the incredibly great
time, but now let's be honest, no one knows
exactly what the company is worth today, even
with a stripe or something like that
No one is going public now because the
market has adjusted. I think
central is an outstanding piece of software.
The company is growing very strongly. By the way, we
have just made a partner of
ours the CEO and he
has come on board with that, so we are taking
a lot of care  about the company Alex Koch
my CTO is there Co CTO is building the
technology with the company is
developing operationally and in terms of
sales it is
still worth a billion today that
the market will now answer when
the next big
companies
do it again  So the new multiples
of software service industry will be
found, but we
also have something like a liliium there, of course
you can see the public
price, which has actually just
gone down a lot, although the company is
developing outstandingly and there is
no one here either  Investment advice we
have an incredibly strong
satellite company which is cash flow
positive where we
build our own awesome satellite technologies in Sofia
so we have really good good things in the
portfolio okay and but that is
really your private money yes yes exactly so
now for the 100th  % but also
always to a very large extent our
money but the highlights you say
are somehow central satellites in
Sofia are still Lilium or
yes Lilium I think so
you can read the stock market price exactly
but I believe that overall
The company is currently not correctly
valued, my personal assessment is
that it will be successful and then
it will also
be worth many, many billions because it
simply redefines the industry, the
satellite company, we just have
cancer medication,
which is really on a very good path  Of
course, I can't
judge it myself, I'm not a biologist. We
have these biologists and I think there are
very good people on board, but from what
I hear from the experts, there
really is a chance of a good
breakthrough
and yes, what we have, we have robots
That's how we got started and
we really have a power block D.
We've just raced a big round of energy storage even
in difficult times
we care
extremely closely about the companies
and I think that's our our
magic source aha, um now if you
hear it like that, the food portfolio
is actually almost sold off in large parts,
um then the public
activities around 10x DNA which you can also do
can see you say somehow 15
million now magnitude maybe
somehow 7 A8 of your money in there
and then the Tech VC that means the foodg
is d everything flows everything in Tech or
or do you have another one do you make
other investments or so no I  I'm
really pure 10x DNA so that's my
my money with all the volatility and
venture capital that's really where
I have my money but that means
the portfolio is probably
worth significantly more than
the public portfolio you're
currently in  Ask the big Florian
or whatever the big VCS what
the portfolio is worth. To be
fair you just have to say
we don't know. I don't think it would be
okay to say I now know exactly
what my portfolio is because we
come into the world  where things
are priced differently but exactly overall
the VC portfolio is certainly a lot
more, a lot more, so we're talking about
now, let's say if you
calculate carefully, it's still
about 100 million plus paper
money, I think yes, yes, so that's it
for someone who, so to speak,
did everything himself in the end, somehow you
didn't inherit anything or nothing,
um if that were the case and
one day it can be liquidated
or in the sense of being able to generate cash from it, there are
n't
that many of them  have somehow created that for themselves,
no, and I believe and
I also believe that there is still something that
would be more of a depressive value, exactly I
think there is much more that can be done
and I have now made a very clear commitment to
always invest 95% back,
so that I  I'm really
investing in tech again
because
my heart just bleeds when
I see prosyon that means the
potential drug against cancer that
the team could still use more money
to make faster progress in research
and we in  Germany has so
few people who really
provide capital, we have
now seen 500
million super from Bosch SAP
and the black group, but
we actually need more people who can
then just 100 million in
important topics like  a Lilium and so on
and that's why
I hope that it
's significantly more and will be significantly more
so that I can give the money back
and we can provide certain impetus
because we're getting further and further
behind from the USA and China  and
that's the mission I'm on
and now it was with the
valuation correction that took place in all VC
portfolios, it was a
small setback but that's part of it in
hindsight when you now see what you
would do in your text day in the background anyway  you do this TX DNA fund this
public fund again yes that
's just too good so I believe
that it's exactly the right strategy
why we're expanding our free spirit team
to include more physicists chemists biologists
we'll get a
continuous cash flow in if we have
more  You can't get assets under management
like in the WC
where sometimes when you've
put everything in the market in
good companies you suddenly say oh how
finanzi actually the big team
has stability here and there to say
we can  All of these
outstanding minds perform well and are well-
financed.
By the way, I also know that they, like the
teams,
both sit together in our office in Bonn and how much
they have already learned from each other. We
looked at the seed phase and battery technology and then went
to Shinji  The chemist went over and is
currently making batteries in the public market
and all these learnings that we
bring back and forth are much bigger
than expected, so yes, I would
do it the same way again and I believe
that it will all still be quite successful,
even if it is currently  of course
going through a difficult time okay okay
so that the setbacks of your
personal brand if you will
you take the purchase then screw it too
so I mean I know that
some people think I like to be in the
spotlight and so on but that's the way it is
secondary, you can use it and
I think I'll hopefully use it
quite effectively for our companies. You
also have a reputation, you know
what you can do with it, but
whether a few of
my memes are running on TikTok somehow, that's
not really  important,
okay, when people watch you, you know
someone who inspires you. Every
now and then there are those who have the analogies Elon Musk has also had very
turbulent years behind him. In fact,
you are
completely enthusiastic about it, how do you see
him? He is the greatest entrepreneur  that there
ever was,
he delivers, he can do what he can
do, we are now seeing that a
competitor to Open AI
has launched within four months, which is
not yet on the current four turbo
version but will certainly
get there soon, um humanly he does  So I
'm just not happy, I do
n't know, fifth wife and no house
and so no no apartment no
moving back but really always
full of fire I think he wants it that way
I really like the biography you
read too  impressive
and very very very
impressive and I also
listened to many interviews with Walter
to see how he spoke to him and
he said no one has ever let me
get as close to his life
as Elon, that's what this biography is called
Seems to be really authentic
and she shows again very well what makes
him tick and I think that's
an absolute role model for me in
entrepreneurship, not for my
private life. I'm very
happily married to my first
wife and wanted that too, so to speak
lead home that then wanted to
die with her um I have different values
different way and so on but wow but
entrepreneurially it's really
great and I just
got the new Model 3 Highland two days ago and one of the
disadvantages of  Tesla was they had the
best battery and so on, the best
technology, software and so on but the
things still
rattled a bit, you just have to
say I still think it was the
best car and I enjoyed driving it for a long time
but they were if
the door was slammed shut, certain things
were simply not processed on the top notch.
Now the Model 3 Highland
has arrived, it is so perfectly
processed and nothing rattles
anymore, which makes me so happy because it has
now made it into production
and he is building  yes, also profitable, which
when you see how much Ford and others
lose per car, that means he has
really achieved something again, which was enormous, so it
was not only the best eV but
now also an outstanding car
with gaps and so on that can be
built profitably  Deep respect, so as an
entrepreneur, we also shoot
up our satellites with SpaceX with him. I
always have one or two
connection points there too,
but the whole Twitter
development, that is, the takeover at 44
billion, which is now
maybe 8 billion in some books  It's worth that's
already 16, I think it was just the
current contracts but that doesn't
matter at all. Now you say, look out, he
bought this company too expensively, but
we all did that, everyone who
did any venture capital round at the time  whether Squire project
A9 freigy we do seed but we
all bought at the same valuation
the malultipils have just
come down and now look at
all the companies on the
stock market have come down whether they are so
strong now so the question is also what
company is worth  laid off 70 or 80% of the
people
and today has a software that
I use every day that works much better and is
finally being
developed further, but I mean there are all
these, um, let's say
filter functions and and and and
moderation issues that are also
important  were for many, I think they are
no longer there so that the platform
also loses traffic or at least
loses intelligence because people no
longer
want to be there, so um I do
n't want to defend myself here, I'm no
longer a shareholder um but I believe
that this community  Notes
work outstandingly and that there is a
lot of bad press there because
he sometimes speaks out against the press. I
think overall from a
technological point of view the platform is
stable, it has new functions, it is
developing further, but yes, I
think it already has that  Well done,
the timing, he also said himself
that the chaos was of course stupid on Peak, yes
I mean it's also for his
personal reasons, so he comes into all the halls
in Pulia, that he has to get into the
moderation himself, that he
now asks how it works  he so these
these hassweets that there are
around and why why are they allowed there
and is that really is that
really makes the world better no yes that
's not my expertise and
I don't want to get too deeply involved in that
but if this Twitter  Files votes
and if what really
happened in terms of collaboration with the stat was
who was blocked in what arbitrary
way or the
account that was that wasn't good so
actually you have to say thank you
to someone, whether it's Elon or whoever
always buys this social network
in order to run it properly again afterwards
and not to be in it with a
complete bias that my
view is on it, I have myself there but I
can't read into everything,
I haven't read in deeply about it
your, you are also a
social media expert, it's
crazy what came out of it or
how it was done and that no one
understood the code anymore and of course
I mean that this company
was somehow not functional before
that or yes  made losses
at the time when people asked themselves how
could it actually be that there was
a letter from
Scott Galloway who
somehow wanted to short it and then
wrote to the board at the time
and argued  I think he
actually captured what was going on quite well back then,
but whether
Elon Musk's measures are now really
right, I have a bit of it, so to speak,
so if you read the book
you'll see some of him like him
in the factories there changes things and
just throws out some robots
or somehow moves
the servers for Christmas and deals with things really really
hard
in order to, say,
make factories productive or
more efficient or something like that and I
I think that you can't
easily transfer that to a
social network like that, that your
engineering skills
aren't as in demand or
don't work the way they do now, at least
in factories or
rockets. That's what I've learned and
I think it's helped me  The Albert
Wenger podcast also says that the
guy is an amazing
engineer
and that's what drives him, but with the same
dynamic you don't necessarily win in
the social media world. I'm very, very
glad that he's not a coom because,
on the one hand, especially for us  we are
invested in Tesla and on the other
hand we also work with SpaceX
so I'm happy for every
minute that Elon puts into Tesla or SpaceX and
not
I do
n't think it's as negative as most people to take over or get involved,
I'm a bit more positive,
okay, where are you currently active? I mean,
you have somehow, so I think Linkin is your
house and farm platform,
or the
second one  Most followers in Germany, yes,
exactly and you are still there for you,
what h you years ago I think Z at
klapphaus times I spoke that you
say that you have a team around you
three four people who, so to speak,
accompany you through all the activities in the media
as before, yes, exactly, we are
very, very, very small, I think, a very
powerful team. I have
learned to appreciate having your own voice,
that you have this reach
that you also have and then to
say I have my can mine
put out your own statements, make my own
communication and that's just
my my my channels and that certainly links in
with me at a distance the
number one suits me too because it
's simply a professional business community I
started a newsletter there Innovation PS who
has  now 130,000 subscribers what do
I think you are Dr pretty good pretty good um exactly and that's
why yes and
we're also on YouTube we
have a podcast and so on but that's
really just to
communicate my technology, I do
n't have any at all yet  cents
in advertising, advertising revenue and SAS
are generated and we want to expand this further
because I think
German CEOs could also do this better. It is
important to have this voice. Of
course, Elon now has a very,
very big voice and can use it well again and again
and why  should our dackos
Herbert this, for example, also did that well,
really, or now in Tim hötkes,
I think more people should
be active because it is valuable
to have your own network, but as soon as you
do that, you of course get a
very strong and very visible one
So I mean there's a headwind, you have to have
the tele
haters, so I don't know who the haters are,
but I know there are
some regulars in our environment here who are completely
critical of it, but then
I think there are still some of them  I do
n't know now, they
tend to be even more
emotionally angry. I think the PIP
we're talking about is always
very cool, sometimes bitingly sarcastic,
but I don't think it's emotional with
others. I have the feeling that
maybe it really is
People just because we get angry or
are somehow clean there is a
brutal backlash to me, yes,
I think that's how it is in the you do
n't have that at all, so I have neither, I
think you're just
loved by everyone,
probably I think  He doesn't get anything, but
he never gets what he can
do what he wants, that's really funny,
he can do plastic, so I like Dieter,
but he can do plastic advertising for
Lidl where everyone else would say, and
everyone thinks it's great  He can
sit on a private jet, celebrate all if
but if it's a Deuter,
so it's great if you have a brand like that
and that's good if you're so loved there too,
but I think most men
I wouldn't join in under any circumstances
Comparing the Bohen or something like that or
in range is something different and
I basically just post
our content and
not like that. You are a
political person, I have to say that I
think you h politics is not a good idea,
so politics is not a good one
Idea if you want to have peace in social media,
I can
definitely underline that twice and
I'm more likely to get more involved now with the federal elections, so
of course my media team is
n't really keen on it either because they say
it's real  a good idea Frank,
but for me it's just too important that
I see things in Germany, I
know almost all the ministers personally,
I know what's happening there, I know what's
happening in France and other European governments
think like the USA and I want to
raise my voice  but that's
just not not that's not
conducive to, so which party would that be for,
um, that would be for a sensible
economic policy and a
sensible environmental policy and you have to
see who then has sensible concepts,
it's certainly not the left, it
's certainly not an AFD  As far as
I know today, these are the ones, but the
party may reinvent itself, not
the Greens, but I'll
look into that because I'm just
interested in who is good for our country,
so who is making progress? I just have
the impression that some ministers in
our country  The government is really incompetent
and that really depresses me,
so the office is very upset with you.
Our foreign policy is
not good at the moment and unfortunately we have
a lot of need because
we all know that we are living in these bad times
I think the
foreign policy is not good, the
economic policy is not good because
we have a lot of open
letters from the
family business owners from the DAX
boards who
have really just written down what is really
stupid right now,
we have a lot to do  high electricity prices it
wasn't smart to shut down the nuclear power plants we
just don't have an overall plan how
can you actually
shut down Germany's strong power? At least
now the Greens haven't decided that that
was already decided in the that's true so
I have a friend yes that but you could have
you have to stop when you
saw that you have all these
ideas so we ourselves have
invested there, for example we have a power block that is very,
very important energy storage for the
green energy transition so I think so
we have to do it just when you
saw that we  If you just did
n't make it so quickly then
you would have had to react differently and would
n't have been there so s two three theses
for the for the memory so one
is the nuclear power plants switch them off you
are not happy with what was the Z then you
tell me it doesn't matter  Whether the nuclear power plant is shut down,
I just want cheap electricity that
hopefully leaves as little footprint as possible
on our environment and
we simply didn't do that wisely
because the government had already
made bad decisions beforehand. In
any case, the current government is
also suffering from the fact that the price of electricity
is exploding  is because of the war for which
they can't do anything either, ne alsoof that or exactly yes yes
and it was
certainly normal I do
n't speak for a party at all but I
speak for the country and I want
that we that we in Germany
good good  Make a decision and of
course it was simply not wise,
which many have already seen,
that we have become so dependent on Russia.
I have exactly
all the historical developments now, some
decades ago, um, okay,
is there anything current that was
the last one  For months now, you've been
annoyed by what you could have
done either way and you say
the wrong path was chosen. The
akbs could have continued.
I think we
have to do a lot more
with the startups, too. I mean,
Christian Miele is there  I'll do a
virena soon, so things have
n't been implemented the way we
all hoped, so yes, there are
a lot of topics that concern me, but
before the next one, I would have
bet on it and I would have
expected it now  That you might have something to say,
because I hear it more often, is the
fact that we work so little with
stock pensions. That's
actually an issue that
I think many in the business world
argue understandably if
we don't finance our pensions through stocks in some way
want how how
else should it work and that is a topic that is
close to home, I absolutely believe that the
stock pension and also stocks are
very important in German, but I would definitely
not do that. H you mention it
somewhere because then maybe
rightly so  It's said that
Frank is now suddenly pushing stocks because he
has a stock, so I'm staying
out of that, but now I'll say it in a completely neutral way,
please not my fund, but other broadly
diversified stocks make a lot of sense. In
my opinion, they should
have a tax incentive if you  It lasts a long time so that
people
can build up a pension or Hal an
old age cushion and exactly and you should use
what Germany manages in terms of
assets for the pension, which
unfortunately isn't that much
in stock investments, which is what
Norway and other countries do very
much  Well, yes, I think that's when
you
look at this pension system financed by a levy, I think
you can see mathematically that it
will be difficult in the future and that's
what Christian Hecker or he Po also said to
various people
here who have already talked about it
I think it's somehow a development that
we have to adapt to, whether it's all
some German funds but
at least somewhere very broad
control in some of them. The Germans are
afraid of stocks and that's
bad. We are people who have very, very
few stocks because we're afraid of
them  Have volatility and that is a
problem because history has proven that holding
stocks long-term and widely diversified
is, at least so far, historically
the best investment or one of the
best you
can make. On the other hand, stocks
speak like that, especially in the startup scene
Companies that then
probably disappoint a lot of people
or take away a lot of people's interest in shares. There
are now also companies that
we've taken a bit of a step back
because here's the social chain
group, you know the protagonists
from his time on the TV show in the lion's den
With Georg Hofler and
Ralf Dümmel, incredibly nice guys
were also on the podcast and told D about the company
and I think they
were optimistic because the company has
now even gone into public or
or or is no longer there, you were
there too, yes I was too  Investor in
the social chain so simply
private because I also
know Dümmel well and also appreciate it
and
found the concept actually
coherent, yes because what you said is that they
bring
the sales pressure out of the show
that I do  Yes, I have experienced myself that he
can be very positive. Now you can
say that a show like this should be
made into sales, but that's what you can make of it.
I think Ralf, the way I got to
know him, was always a hard,
honest-working guy who
was really keen on the products too
Selling every product now
makes sense, you can discuss it. George
brought this whole social media group with him, social chain, as it was
called, so to speak, it made
a lot of sense to me and I
have to say it was extremely surprising that
this bankruptcy was declared
because  Yes, Georg too, just after
public feilings, I didn't
have any insider information and I had massively refinanced it, so as I
read it from the outside, it also
surprised someone internally
that S also a few
hundred out of millions way no not
millions but so exactly so it
was
a a small position in my
portfolio just out of the out of
the friendship with out of Ralf
where I also believed in it
and yes that has me  I'm really surprised
and I'm also excited because there
are actually good assets still in
the company. For example, we have three
bears that are also doing pretty well, they're
also still in this company,
we have
shares in it together, so I'm curious  As it
continues, it was
very
surprising to me. In general, it's already the
time of bankruptcies right now, so you're
getting it everywhere, right and left.
Yes, the problem is money has
become expensive. We're now
very lucky with our portfolio, or hard work
as well  always with Freigeist
but the problem is that the
connection subsidies don't come any more, it
was the money that was there, it was very cheap
and now all of a sudden it's expensive
and then you think about exactly where do
I continue to finance it, maybe it's
a very healthy development because then
maybe  Startups and other
companies also survive that
shouldn't survive. Maybe there was
a bit too much money before, yes, but it's
unpleasant at first. I think we'll
see a lot of bankruptcies this year and next, that would also be my
assessment. Did you actually invest with Mr. Benko, who
does real estate?
I think there are four construction sites in Hamburg
that are currently at a
standstill. I think that's
still a drama for me. I'm not invested at all
and it's not my industry, but
these property developers
built it with cheap money, so to speak  Then there were
families who saved for a long time, made
a down payment on a house
that the developer then built,
maybe even took out a loan for it
and now the
developer is going bankrupt and they will never
move into their house. These are really
heartbreaking situations and I  I have
no idea if
politics should really
intervene. I have no idea, but
we will almost certainly see very bad
and many bankruptcies and
the completely wrong people will be hit if it
hits a Ralf Dümmel if it hits me
if it hits me too
As a professional entrepreneur,
we know our risks when it
happens to a family or someone alone
who has been saving for a long time for their apartment
and then suddenly always thought
I bought it, the apartment must be
mine, I have to  say, it's
really a really
unpleasant situation and you could
perhaps make a difficult decision and
think about whether the start will
help people. Real estate isn't for you at all,
so you don't make
any real estate investments yourself
anywhere Z security in the background
or something like that  We have two decent
properties, we live there every now and then and that's
it, so we don't rent anything out there
and I'm definitely not going
to do any real estate in any way okay okay yes well now there's
also a down phase where you can get started
I think yes I think I'm a friend
of  I think he's very, very active in the
real estate sector, and
I think it's similar
to tech stocks, but I know them
very well, so I'd rather buy
a little more 10x DNA, it's
the same situation
I think it's very cheap if you're someone who
knows a lot about real estate and
can now buy the right real estate from the insolvent property developers. I
think I can now
make historically outstanding investments,
but that's not my field
Georg Kofler Ralf Dümmel also
plays a role for you. Do you think that you
can really assess
how you affect people because you
affect so many millions of
people who you don't even know
and whose background you
don't know?  So I really know it, I think it's
very difficult, so I do
n't have this exposure to me, someone
else listens to the podcast, but it's
a completely different flight and that's
why I'm wondering a little bit about
it  From the perspective
you actually understand how you appear and
who you appear there because it's
very, very broad, i.e.
millions of viewers on television
and somehow you also have
hundreds of thousands of followers -
that's no longer so easy
to
grasp  No, and I
thought about it at the very beginning, do you have to
put a filter on it now, for example, say pay attention,
Frank, you really have a reach now, so you
speak more calmly, maybe
you don't say things that you would otherwise say anymore because that
could upset people  Even if it
is your honest belief and I
have made a fairly conscious decision
not to do that but to
remain who I am, to give my honest
opinion, to hopefully never
use my tone, to hopefully never
be personally attacking, but
not, for example, my enthusiasm
for an entrepreneur like Elon Musk
to slow down because then a social
media team says then you are even more
popular that would certainly be an
easier way
but I am who I am and the
nice thing is when I meet old friends
they always say hey when I see you  I
see or something like that, you're just the Frank,
you're just the way you've always been, yes
and I think of course maybe
they want to be nice to me,
but that's actually my my
my benchmark and of course he'll
offend and  then
haters are also generated with haters
m but I just try
to do my stuff honestly and calmly and yes
and I have decided that I wo
n't change that just because I
reach more people that would
n't recommend me to other people, for example
Angela Merkel, who I really appreciated,
even though she also
made political mistakes, so in
my opinion it was crass, which
I also understand after so many years in
the unbelievable public, how
filtered she spoke because she
was so trained not to offend
and so on  and I think I can
understand that but I think it's the
wrong way, I think it's even more so for people
or and if you
have a lot of publicity, stay who you are, speak
honestly and authentically and do
n't put a filter on it so that somehow
fewer people might be upset. There are
countries where  you
actually say the political developments are
positive, so I mean if you look at the
USA it would also be difficult, yes,
I hear it more often,
um, I recently saw
the English Prime Minister, Mr.
Sunak, with Elon Musk in an interview with
this ai
So there are people or people
or countries where things are actually going quite
well. In my opinion we should
take a closer look, so fre Heinemann was
enthusiastic about Mr. Macron
elegant politician who can take you with you,
who also invites the big Americans
to Paris again and again and they
come and who can
perform much better there, e.g.  Olaf Scholz
now the interview with the Prime Minister of the
UK I thought was very good, so
he's deep into the topics and I do
n't think an Olaf Scholz like that could do that with us because he simply
has no idea about it and isn't that deep into the topics  It
's in there, but I have
n't prepared anyone yet.
I'll take it with me as homework because instead of
always modding and saying that
Germany and the USA are stupid, I'm also
very critical of both of them
Don't judge, but when
a man is so old that he doesn't even
know where he is anymore and that
's only very often very clearly
documented, then it's just
no longer the case, so it just doesn't fit
anymore, so maybe a
good next one  Social Media Post good
good politicians that inspire me so
I'll take it with me I ca
n't think of any in Germany right now anyone W tell
them I'd like to support them
so they're cross-party so
not cross-party so there are
cross-party politicians in Germany no no
I'd like to give my opinion  Well, that's well
known and I absolutely support
Christian. I'll certainly
support him again in the next federal election as a head if he ever does this crazy thing again. I appreciate
Christian because he understands things
when I'm with him  I'm talking about then he
knows how companies work, how
the economy works, he's
still involved in the topics, he knows what a
blockchain is and so on, and I
think he really seriously wants to
do good for Germany, that's
the head in his head
I will continue to support the current government, which I still think is good,
but I'm also
not happy with the overall result of the government.
Okay, what is
the endgame for you? So what does Frank do?
My endgame in 20 years is that I donate the assets
to the environment and
uh uh education that means I think those are
the two big issues we we have
an educational gap that we
don't that people don't
get good education anymore if we
have smart next generation make the
good decision so that's my theory
and also elect smart politicians  and so
on so education is extremely important and
the other thing is the environment, I don't
just take the climate, the climate is an issue,
we have many, many more other
bad issues in our environment and
then I will try with the capital
that will hopefully be a lot white
Nobody, above all,
to bring in my entrepreneurial experience
because it's not that easy, there's just
not enough capital to really
implement things effectively and then,
um, together with my wife if she
also has the drive and still
loves me and so on  a lot of
question marks in 20 years um then the
uh exactly the capital for the most part
to be used for these two topics uh hopefully effectively but I know that
is very very difficult so that means
then setting up a foundation and
then how is it from a tax perspective or something like that
I don't know, I haven't thought
about it, so foundations are
usually tax-optimized
for good reasons because you
do it as a non-profit, but maybe
you don't need a foundation at all, so I
think overall it could even
come out that you don't
donate it completely but instead  that there are
progressive
founders who are working on the right
mission and then maybe
for profit, so that's too
far away to say how would I
do that, but my goal will then
no longer be
to generate returns but rather
So to speak, handing over the money to the next
generation with a good impact
on education and the environment is it
then in what tax bracket is
it that you really simply
donate it or is it even that you
simply give out money in a very progressive way
for founders?
I haven't thought about a good mission work yet
because it's easy,
I still have a lot to do on my
current issues when that means
but we're talking about in 20 years then
only then I can't
tell you  Maybe never because I'll
just die, let's say I
have an accident or I have a
stroke or something like that then then then
you're basically out of the current
day-to-day business now
ideally I stay reasonably
healthy then I would be at some point in five
to 10  Years go out of the
day-to-day business of 10x10a and
free spirit that everyone knows
exactly and would then just transition
probably won't do that from
now on but then transition
then just invest my my time in these
other topics but a topic
that is involved  You haven't thawed out yet,
which is also a very
popular topic in the USA, is longevity,
i.e. living longer, looking younger in
all facets. There are some
extreme cases like the PayPal founder or
something like that, the one who, I
think you mean, Brian Johnson
or becomes an American entrepreneur  I'm
hoping to be on stage with us in May
or at least to
be there, who is a little too sure about getting a blood
transfusion from his son
and a crazy story. Let's
see Brian Johnson, but that's just
the one who is extreme in general,
also the nels  Regge was a completely different
example a dozen years ago.
Here we do something like that too, so it's a
very modern topic of various
kinds, very extreme and social media is
a bit too real about research and
medicine, but that leaves you cold, nope,
nope, I mean, that's it  Is that
afterwards when you have all the money and
so what what do you want another
mega eight more that that that that that of course what drives
Jeff Basos and
Christian Angermeier and also then
says how can I
enjoy what I have built for as long as possible  I think it's
probably or how can
I create value for as long as possible that's
really exciting and we're
already investing in biotech, which is why, for example, it
could be that
our investments will help me at some point,
but yes, that will simply
become a normal investment field for me
We don't have a focus on it at the moment,
but I think it's
really exciting to do it yourself. You're
not going to take any measurements
and see how much you sleep
and what you eat and I sleep a lot.
I try to take a
cold shower, that's it  It's really not that stupid,
so that's one of the most important
things. I'm not overweight right now.
Yes, that's
also important. I'd like to weigh a lot
more because I like to eat so much, but that's
exactly what
I do  Just as we
speak yesterday I saw Ky flaume,
who is a few years
older. Marathon in New York in 33,
well, Kai flaume, he doesn't know how
many pull-ups and push-ups and has no
idea what exactly he can do
so so so moving towards Kai flaume
is also another thing on
my agenda but priority B but I
definitely think it's really great if
you live a healthy life and deal with it, but
at the moment my desk is still burning with
other topics but yes, I think it's good  me
you can already see that there are always
investment sectors that are
actually functioning and that
longevity feels somehow hot despite all the tension and interest,
and
that then goes into a bit of
nutrition topics and tracking and
super exciting, so I think so  everyone
if we can do that
and I think we will achieve a lot of things so that we can be
fit until we reach 100.
Life is really cool and you can be
so knowledgeable about everything, I
mean, you also have a lot of energy now,
no, what you do, what what  What do I think
my thing is that I have a good
overview, a good feel for
things, I already know a lot but
unfortunately not that much in depth,
you can't do that anymore, but I'm like that,
I feel like the person up there is basically with
others  People who have an overall view
and then we have our
physicists, our chemists, biologists
and robotics experts with whom you
then go in. But biology, for example, is
certainly the weakest field of
mine because I have never
dealt with physics in biology, I
think so too  I'm now pretty good,
not brilliant, but exactly biology
is definitely the one where I
just like prcion, for example, we also
invested, trust the experts, am
enthusiastic about the founder and say here
's where the money goes, but can I
really judge that at all  Not at all, that's
why we don't have any
biotech in the 10x DNA or if only very
little and and then certain topics that
we play there because we understand them to some extent.
We also have biologists but
not that much because because you have to be
really difficult and very difficult
there  To invest successfully in this
area, what do you do to
relax? Do you still go skating? No,
very rarely, almost not at all. I've seen snowboarding and
fishing. Yes,
I skate a lot in the summer
with the thing about it that's cool
exactly and I f snowbard okay but otherwise
nothing no I'm really so my
life is also really well paced
describe it so because if you're
here now in Hamburg then you'll
probably still be in
Hamburg tonight somehow appointments or
in the afternoon  and then no, I'll be
back in the office this evening in okay okay WoW
and then you'll do such a great
working hours so that you're not that crazy
When I
work, I think it's effective and
very, very strong, yes, okay,
so Jeff B model, which you
can also see that he has just
moved to Miami with his new wife
and has changed his body a bit,
that could also be a preliminary
For you, the lifestyle is the
other person who says somehow now now
fun apparently no I don't have
fun yet so I enjoy what I
do and fun I really enjoy doing what I
do that fills me up inside
I think fun is the wrong term
for that and if that changes and I
then hopefully do that with the same
woman and not the young
friend who had the operation
then maybe
I'll chill out more but at the moment
you don't feel a certain
responsibility for whom
or for
what  Maybe that's too big now,
but for everything that I
've created and it's totally clear to me
that I was incredibly lucky in terms
of timing that I was born exactly in this
strange App Store era and then dhdl
and no idea what and  I want to
be useful I want I
want to help I want I don't want to
go to bed at night and think horny
I've somehow
consumed something and I want to
give something back I want to create something that
makes me happy too So that
's it  a strong
responsibility that I then feel
towards
society in the end, because look,
the body, for example, would never
say now, I hope I
just weigh 150 kg, but also with my
health, I'm grateful that
I'm healthy  is that I, that I
can walk, that I have a good brain, that
I can see, that for me is also
a way of knowing where you then
behave sensibly and don't just
shoot yourself off into the corner with drugs and do
nothing more, but also
capital knowledge  Healthy body network
is a responsibility for me and I
want to do something useful with it and
do something good, yes being useful as well as I
believe Arnold Schwarzner
published the book, so
that you give something back and that you
do something and that you are grateful  is that you
have all of that, it's
not just like that for me, but I'm
really happy that I have that, so
also WN, the country here or the
system in which you grew up makes
a lot of things possible for you, yes, that
Time, above all, no, we are in
this Internet, I
grew up in the Internet era, where
Florian Heinemann and everyone else
comes from, and that's exactly where I
made my first fortune, yes, okay,
yes, well, but I mean in the end too
the structure in which you live, that there are
some people, yes, yes, the world does
n't exactly have any streets, even less,
not many street fights
and that you
can live safely here, that you
have a certain level of education and so of course
that's good  and I would also like to
preserve that in Germany. Are you
really worried about
street fights now? We already have
wild marches here. I think we have
climate adhesives. They were
n't so bad that they
were aggressive, but some of them were
just blocked things that
I don't think are good, things are simply
destroyed, so I still think that we still have
some things that I just do
n't think is great that they're
happening in Germany, so
again, no worries about my own
safety, but we're all going to
them  right direction and do we have
a positive attitude do we want to
get better we want to
become more peaceful do we want to do more sport
think more do more good things or do
we have more and more mobs and more and
more fights in the street and
burning cars and things like that, those are the
pictures  They concern me a
bit with the question, what are you looking at? Well,
there are always what numbers do
you really take seriously now, so recently
I was really excited, I saw
that there are more people in sports clubs
than ever before,
so it's good news and at the same time,
but  The world view is then dominated
by negative things anyway because there are incidents here and
there somewhere that are
of course made incredibly big,
but do you have the feeling that in
today's world you even manage
to have a clear view of
what is happening because  the numbers are bombarded from all
sides, negative
news runs
better, it's difficult to say
exactly that, in part and I ca
n't even cover that, then
some wild things are shown that
were 10 years ago or something and that's just what it
says  Now Berlin is burning
and then somehow it's not
Berlin at all or something
else, exactly, this fake news
and, above all, the control of
how much negative news do you see and
why isn't even
the sports clubs have record numbers on the daily topics?
I'm definitely with you and
we also follow a good news thing
on Ex and so on. So I think we
need more good
news sometimes but overall I think
we're
not having an easy time, especially with the wars and stuff like that
If you say you're so worried
about Europe, what has to
happen there? I think we first have to
wake up and realize how serious the
situation is, the problem is,
things are still going reasonably well these days, then
digitalization stalls a bit and
then we'll discuss it  about how and whether
we expand the 5g network and we are
coming to a time where things are
developing exponentially, we are seeing this
again for a short time, the new
open ai keynote very very impressive
how quickly this is developing so we are
now coming to a time where  Artificial
intelligence from other
providers will also really develop strongly
where infrastructure from
space is suddenly provided 250 m at
every point in the world and so on and
Europe plays a part in this, we have
quantum computers, we have software,
we have media networks that also have a power
Of course, we have to play out and I
think that Europe is losing it a little bit
in a small way, that we
need a moon landing like that, where we
really say, pay attention, we are restarting
Europe and we are investing
progressively and courageously in important things
and e.g. fusion energy, I believe with
you  The team has also been on the
podcast before. Um, it absolutely has a chance of
working. I can't tell you
whether it will work. I have to
ask other experts, but many experts
say there is a fair chance that it will
work well in 5 to 15 years.
Why is this going to happen?  so laughed at in
Europe, why don't we say okay, it's
a real chance, let's step on the gas and
many other issues, so I think we
have to wake up in Europe and we
have to realize that
unfortunately we're behind in many places technologically,
um and
er, I can see that  the politics have
not yet been depicted so simply mhm mhm um
yes the Heike friend no the lady
you're talking about the one that does that
Marvel Fusion yes um there's even
a rumor that they're going to go to the USA now they're
going to braen the production in the
USA  I'm still going through
it briefly in my head because I'm just going through what
we've discussed so
far. If you say both of them should
resign, then not to
completely clear the way for Trump,
but to perhaps also
make it possible for another democratic candidate
I'm staying out of that, so I'm
not in the USA, I wouldn't be
allowed to have an opinion there either, so I do
n't think Donald Trump is cool at all,
so I think he's not a good
person,
yeah, what just moves me now
It's because it's so important to Hal
that you have a strong voice in the USA,
that this person is very obviously
no longer fit for the job to me, that's
what concerns me. I would
like to have someone young, super good if
you even have a female one  Candidate Candidate
thinks some young,
young, educated, good drive guy but
somehow that doesn't seem to get out of this
political system,
so I don't think Donald Trump is not
good, but now just
objectively B the way I've experienced him,
at least he still knows  where he
is but of course it would definitely
not be my dream candidate so um
give me a little bit of
schitztorm coaching you've had a lot of different coaches over the
years
exactly Verauf exactly
and I think some of the Z
Z probably always will, even on a smaller scale  That's
how it goes in
today's world in which we live.
We've probably
had it again and again because of
various topics, but I've just
had a relatively big one in your
podstar environment
around Mr. Precht  I
saw it from a distance and I can't talk to him, that's why what, um, what do
you do, how do you approach it? First of all, what was
the worst FW person? That's of
all the shitstorms that have been
around  lit you up, what was the
worst I think um that he
came up with so many topics in one place, it
was basically in the sunshine
of the media for years and then suddenly due to
my political commitment
one or the other tried to tell me
some nonsense
Back then, Twitter was still relatively left-wing,
simply from a buabble point of view, and then
you were already very, very often
trending number one on Twitter with
topics that weren't positive, and
then some other unfortunate
things, so it was more like that  then
suddenly many in a very short time I
think that was my mine but it GB
not one incident man that was
now a statement where the most common thing
was rejected so no there are
often no statements at all but
what people are trying to do is
something to you  to insinuate what you didn't even
say or something like that, that's how
shitstorms often work, that you
consciously say that you
leave out the second half-sentence even though it's totally
crucial in what context or
that a lot of it
was completely made up for me, just completely, yes
and  D doesn't even care about that
anymore, even in the big newspaper it
said that I had a very strong argument with them, I said that
I never said that and
fortunately I also had an
audio recording where it was very clear that I
never said that  We then
agreed to not agree
but yes, that's actually
the problem that something is then simply
invented that I just
clicked well at the moment, let's say, um, you would
now be in financial problems here with OMR,
which isn't the case  In the case
it's somehow rumored and then
I put another dr, yes, he also
told me that he's bankrupt and I
heard he's already sold his car
and you know that's how it is, then just do
the story and it'll work
then just go up and what do you do
then so how do you go about it um I'm woah
these days I think I'm just
relaxed and would or I
haven't had one for a while now
just make a statement about it when
I see the big thing that we we  Look,
it stays in this bubble Twitter or
whatever then we let them
all do what they want somehow.
Post it goes into the media so it goes
into focus Spiegel Stern whatever then
we call the editorial team plus make a
parallel statement and say that does
n't correspond  The truth is the following
happened Frank ten is not broke
because I have no idea or okay but that
means just kind of wait and see how big
it will be, first ignore it for a long time when it
then goes into the right main areas then
say something like that that
has crossed the limit and
then come up with a statement against it like that  That's how
we do it today, yes, and but there are
certainly agencies that do it much,
much better and if my
main focus now was
to protect my brand, then
I would probably be there with a
large team, but that's not my
main focus, what are all of them  Yes,
many have also had success if you
look at it, then your potential assets
are already
very impressive, Ken, what's been going on in the
last few years? If you look back now,
Frank ten has been 20 years old as an investor as an entrepreneur,
the two three biggest wrong
decisions  Wow, that I
was able to do it like that, so financial, but also
maybe communicative, maybe
somehow in general, where
I somehow, well, I think, signed quite earlier
than when I was private for money
that I didn't have and was therefore very
much at risk of private insolvency
which I was
able to fend off at the last second, so running into private
bankruptcy is unpleasant, that was
in my 20s, no, it was very early on and
I simply guaranteed too much money
and said hey, it's all going
up, that's great  awesome 1 million
private guarantors no issue at all I just did
n't have them and then it went
against the wall then certainly issues like those
from flirke that you didn't get there earlier
and more consistently just exactly
what then very that's
incredibly out of hand yes um that
You don't just sit down quietly at the table in front of you
and say, pay attention here,
please give me 1 € here are the shares, we do
n't fit together, it's not a
bad thing for both sides, it just does
n't fit, goodbye, I
just thought too much about it  okay, there
were other investors
there too, so you have to take care of it,
I should have just said
watch out for this party, it's not mine
have a nice day that was definitely
a mistake yes okay so the two
things
V okay okay so I  Thank you very much for the
honesty, for the openness as always
and also for a certain level of transparency, so you
also have a few things back, but
of course you have now given a lot to others,
but I am the
speculation that I would like to know
where your your WC shares  where they
say 100 million have that that no that you said
a depressive estimate
you said okay, I'll take a look at that, let's take a
look at that, so
thank you very much anyway and yes also for
your commitment, so I mean
not many people have to do that  I do
n't think I agree with a fishing statement
in any way and also with
all the investments but that someone
wants to get involved in
Germany for society here,
I think that's great in that respect, thank you very much
for that and then until next time,
thank you both  could be
and see you soon CIA C all ciao ciao
this podcast is produced by
podstars at
OMR